[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESUS CLIMENT: Hello, everybody.
I want to talk about something
that has been extremely--
it has been talked
during the entire Next.
We have had several
presentations
talking about SLOs
and error budget.
I'm going to focus
a little bit more
into how everything
applies once you get paged.
Once you're on call,
and how you set up
everything in a way that allows
you to receive those pages that
don't wake you up in
the middle of the night.
We're going to try to talk--
sorry.
My notes are--
I cannot see them.
So we're going to
try to understand
the reality of complex
systems, understand what
matters to our business
and to our users,
understand tolerance,
understand how to use symptoms
as a way to page us, and then
putting everything together.
So raise your hand if you
have ever been on call.
Raise your hand if
have ever been on call
in the middle of the night.
Keep your hand up if
you have been paged
and, once you got
to your computer,
the problem was
not there anymore.
OK.
So you're in the right
place, most of you.
So first of all,
monitoring is hard.
As I was saying, there are
plenty of monitoring systems
that are alerting for things
that, once you get there,
the thing is not there anymore.
How many times has
an ambulance been
called to just show up and
then it was just somebody that
had a little bit of a
dismayed, lose consciousness,
but he's back to--
or you call the fireman,
the building gets evacuated,
and there's no fire.
It's just like somebody cooking
or doing something similar.
There are many times that you
receive those pages mostly
because when you
start a new service,
when you start your
company, you're
working with small systems,
you're pitching for the causes,
the things that are related
to machine is out of memory.
The CPU is very hard.
Things that matter
to your service,
once you start,
but it starts not
mattering so much when the
service starts growing.
Like, the more
your service grows,
the more machines you
have in your service,
and there is a
lack of correlation
between how your
service grows and how
your operational-- sorry.
There is usually a correlation
when your service size
increases and your system
has a certain capacity
for the operational team.
There is a bad
operational situation
if your operational load
increases at the same level
as your service size increases.
The ideal situation is
that your operational work
grows sublinearly compared
to your service size.
And that it is really
difficult to do
when you don't have the
system base alert system
that I'm going
describe continuously.
Sorry.
So as I was saying,
everything on CPU,
IO starvation,
memory starvation,
it's very normal to be done
when you have small machine,
small set of machines.
But a data center of scale,
it doesn't make much sense.
When you have thousands of
machines that are running,
imagine getting paged
for any of those machines
running out of memory.
It doesn't even make sense at
the level of the data center.
People working in
the data centers
should only get paged when
a certain number of machines
are running out of space or when
are broken, not for every
single one of those machines.
When that happens,
you're actually
having data center
operators running up
and down in the data
center replacing
a single disk on
several machines.
In fact, at Google,
we have perfected
the idea of repairing a
certain number of machines
when they have to be repaired.
And we actually trace the
path that the operator
has to do in order to go
repair those machines.
So single-cause alerting is
definitely not a way to do it.
In fact, if you do the math--
I have here a assertion
that 5,000 machines running
for a single day is
more than 10 years
of a single machine running.
It took 10 years.
In fact, it's something
like 13.69-plus years.
It's just a comparison.
It's not a one-to-one
comparison.
But it's to give you an idea
of how long a single machine
should be running compared to
those 1,000 machines running
in a data center.
There are plenty of
the things that you
have to take into account, like
the mean time before failure,
and the bathtub curve.
In the beginning, you get a
lot of failures in the machines
because there's new components
and they haven't been tested.
Then you have a flat
line, and then you
start getting
errors and breakages
at the end of the lifecycle.
But essentially, the idea is
that running a very complex
system with a large
set of machines
increases the number of errors
that you're going to get.
So it doesn't make sense at all
to page for every single one.
In fact, one of the
principles, when we designed
the precursor of Kubernetes--
Borg-- it was that--
it's not a question of
if they're going to fail,
it's a question of when
they're going to fail.
So essentially, what
we did at Google
was incorporating
the idea of paging
only when the user
experience is affected.
So we move away from paging
from individual causes to paging
only when there's a symptom
that reflects user happiness.
Only page when the
user has been affected,
when the user figures
out that there
is a problem with the system.
So now that we
know that we don't
page for individual
machines going down,
and we only page when the
users are being affected,
let's talk about how we
engineer that error that we
are receiving and we are seeing
in our systems, in our paging.
Ben Trainer came
up with the idea
that 100% is the
wrong reliability
for almost everything.
I would argue that it's
impossible to achieve.
In order to have
100% reliability,
you would have to know exactly
the state of every single
of your components in your
entire system at all times
during the entire lifetime
of those components.
In fact, the user is not going
to know that your system is not
100% reliable because once
you get into an elevator-- who
has a mobile phone?
How many times, during the
middle of a phone call,
and then you get
into an elevator,
and then you cannot
continue that phone call?
Exactly.
It happens.
That error is introduced
not only by the system,
but by your environment.
So it doesn't make sense
to try to fix those errors.
It's better to embrace them
because things will fail.
Things will break during
the natural lifecycle
of the things.
You will have
hundreds of users that
will try to use your
system when there
is the final of the
American football, when
there is an earthquake
in a different location.
People will go to
your service to try
to figure out what's happening.
People will go to pay when
there was a dip on bitcoin
or to get the bitcoins
out of your system.
Also, users will try to
use your service in a way
that it was not designed for.
Google Maps had a
certain peak of use
when people figured
out that they
could get the tiles of
the maps and then start
using them for other
purposes, just to put
the location of your business.
So we had a huge
spike on the traffic,
and we had to include some
authentication to avoid that.
But we had an outage
due to that problem.
Also, people will
use your service
in ways that were not designed,
and people will actually
abuse the service by
hacking your system,
by getting inside and bringing
down your database when
you least suspect it.
Very common to have SQL
injections that suddenly delete
your entire user table, and
you cannot access your service
anymore.
In fact, even Google
fails every now and then.
You barely notice it because
it fails very little,
but it fails.
So the thing that we introduced
to account for that failure
is service levels.
It's not avoiding error.
It's introducing error
in your system in a way
that you can account for it,
so that even if error exists,
your users can mostly operate
and use your service in a way
that it was designed for.
Those concepts are probably
the most important thing
that I'm introducing
today, but they're
pretty much in every
single literature
that we have written,
like in the two SRE books.
It's a service-level indicator.
It's a metric.
It's the first concept
that we're introducing.
It's basically a
definition of an attribute
of your system, an
attribute of your system
being a way that your
user is using your system.
It's exactly what it says.
It's an indicator of how
the service is performing
at a certain point in time.
An example of that would be the
proportion of HTTP GET requests
that you can get
on your homepage.
There are 200, 300, 400,
excluding a certain measure,
but it's measured at
the load balancer.
That is just the indication of
how the service is performing.
A server-level objective is
a service-level indicator
with a specific goal.
So a goal could be that
99.9% of those requests
are successful in a certain
period of time, like 28 days.
There's another concept, which
is a service-level agreement,
which is basically a contract
that you have between you
and the users of your service
that are paying for it in a way
that, if you miss the SLO, if
you run out of error budget,
then your users get a
certain type of compensation.
So now that we have a
definition of an indicator,
and we have a goal
for that indicator,
like a certain level, how
can you find that level?
So a way to find that first
goal, if you don't have
any data of your service, like
your new introducing your SLOs,
the way that you can do
is look at your past.
The expected performance
that you have in the present
is the performance
that your users have
experienced in the recent past.
So that's something
that you can use
to define that first
level of performance
that their service is providing.
It's something that you should
not maintain ad infinitum.
It's something that
you should change
because expectations change.
Past performance is not an
indicator of future results,
so you should go back and see
how the system is performing
at a certain time
in the present,
only to change when the
environment changes.
Imagine trying to get your
phone out of the pocket,
and it's an iPhone 2, and then
connect it into a GPRS network
right now and try to download
your favorite website.
It will probably be a
nightmare, and then you
will hate that experience.
So things change, even
though you don't feel
that the website is changing.
They are loading
it with JavaScript,
they're loading it with more
requests in the background.
So things change in
time and, therefore, you
should be analyzing how
those things are changing
and get to the future.
So now that we have a
certain level in which we
can assume that the
service is going to fail,
we have, for example, 99%--
two nines-- for your service.
You have a certain leeway in
which your service can fail.
So the point is not
to avoid that failure.
It's to embrace it.
And once you embrace it, you
can use it for other things,
like you can test
your environment.
You can test your users.
You can do AB experiments.
You can increase the speed at
which you release new features.
You can put that feature
that you were not
expecting to put because
it's a little bit too risky,
but then you can
put it there and see
how your users are affected.
So now we have what we
are trying to measure
and how we are
trying to measure.
So let's talk about how we
alert on those measurements
that we have.
First of all, we said
that a symptom is anything
that you can
measure with an SLO.
So a way to express
that SLO would
be to measure the
uptime of your service.
That's the availability.
So you measure how
long it stays up
compared to how long it
stays up and stays down.
That is fantastic
for a single machine,
but then we go back into the
complexity of the systems.
Once you have your load
balancers to the front,
you have all the 1,000 machines
responding in the back,
it's almost impossible to
identify that binary in which
you're identifying the uptime.
So what do we do instead is
we define the availability
in a complex system as
the amount of errors
that you receive when
you are receiving traffic
versus all the total requests
that are valid when you're
receiving those requests.
So there you have your
system, you have your SLOs.
You put a prover.
Your prover is testing your
machine every five minutes
or every one minute.
And then your system is telling
you that your system is set up,
you have your availability
numbers that are at 100%.
We're done, right?
No.
We're not right.
Imagine that you have
a Chrome job that
is running every
minute, and it's
loading your service 10
seconds of every minute
at beginning of the minute.
And then you put
your prover that
is only testing your
service every other minute,
and they interleave
with each other in a way
that only you are getting
the good pings, but not
the bad pings.
That is possible to happen.
So in order to
increase the resolution
that you obtained
from your prover,
the thing that we recommend
is increasing the number
that the resolution
of those props
without increasing too much the
traffic that you're creating.
Another way that we can use
is measure the availability
at the application level.
You instrument your
application to save
logs on the request of your
receiving and the responses
that you're providing.
And you can increase the
coverage of the measurement
of availability.
The problem that you're
introducing over here
is that you're only accounting
for the good requests
that you receive.
All the requests that died
at the load balancer level
or died because the
network was down,
you won't be able to see them.
There's an expression
that I put over here.
It's essentially a Prometheus
expression in which you just
put this in your
Prometheus code,
and you can see the availability
in the right numbers,
essentially counting the
request that you receive,
discarding the
requests that are 400,
and then doing the calculation.
Another possibility on how
to measure the availability
is by doing it at the
load balancer level.
You put your measurement
in the load balancer, which
is account the ratio
that you receive, count
the responses that you respond
versus all the responses
that come back from your
back-end web servers,
and are now 200, and voila,
you have a measurement.
Right?
We made it.
We have all the symptoms
that are calculated.
We are creating alerts that
are paging every time that we
are seeing an error on the
availability of our system,
and then happy users.
Not so far.
Once you start paging
for every single error
that your service
is saying, you're
basically counting every
drop as if it were the same.
And that's not reality.
A machine that is dying in the
background, your load balancer
is not fast enough to
move to a healthy machine,
your high-availability
service is not
accounting for those
little glitches
that happen over there.
You don't want to page
for every single failure
that occurs in your system.
What you want to page
is for the SLO burn.
It's the ratio at which the
error is being produced.
So big floods of
errors are accounted
for, small errors
occurring in isolation
are not accounted for.
How do we do that?
We introduce a
little bit of math.
The thing that you
want to calculate
is the burn rate
at which you have--
you define a threshold in which
your error rate is basically
burning your entire error
budget at the end of the window.
In this case, if we have
an average QPS of 1,000,
what we can do is, if
we have an SLO of 99
over a period of a
week, we calculate
that we have a number of
604 million total queries,
and therefore we have a
number of permissible errors
of 6 million-plus.
The idea of calculating
the fast burn error rate
is by calculating that
threshold on how many QPSs
are per second.
In this case, the
threshold would
be about 70 errors per second
that your system is producing.
So what you do next is
defined over that threshold.
You define two regions.
The one region in which your
fast burning of error budget
is going to consume
the entire error
budget at the end
of your window,
and then the area in which you
have a slow burn but at the end
of the error window--
at the end of the
time window, you're
going to just burn a smaller
amount of that error budget.
However, consuming that error
budget in a small amount
will also introduce
some problems,
which is that you will not have
that error budget to experiment
and to do other things.
So what you want to do
is, in the second part,
you want to introduce a
level of notification,
like send a ticket to
your operational team
so that on Monday,
when they get to work,
they can take a look at it.
But they don't have to
respond immediately.
On the other hand, when you
receive a fast burn alert,
that means that you are
affecting your users in a way
that your error budget
is going to be consumed
by the end of that window.
And therefore, it's
something that the system
is being affected by.
It's something that is--
if it goes immediately
to failure, that line,
that blue line--
by the way, I didn't ask,
but anybody is color-blind?
Anyway, the line on the top
that says fast burn, that is,
in this case, a
line that is very
similar to the threshold of
your error budget consumption.
But if you have a
full outage, that line
probably is almost vertical.
Unless you're in the middle
of the night, and then
you're just receiving
very small QPS.
But still, it's
something that you
would like to respond,
because the moment
that you increase the QPS, that
line will be almost vertical
and will be consuming your
error budget almost immediately.
There's an expression
that I put over here.
It's basically Prometheus.
So it calculates
the errors that are
produced in a period of hour.
You would get paged when the
amount of increase errors
in that period of an hour is
bigger than that threshold
line of the error budget.
And here, the
calculations that we
put before, it's like
the number of QPS
that we're receiving
in a period of time
compared to your
target availability
over a period of 24 hours.
So putting it all together.
Once you define what do you
want to measure in your service
through your SLIs and your SLOs,
when you have your availability
target that you have defined,
either through past experience
or through observability of your
service, what you want to do
is not forget observability,
like that old system
that you're using right
now, which, by the way,
I tend to call the
Nagios problem.
When Nagios came out, it was
so easy to just install it
in your machine,
put an SNMP server,
and then immediately
you would get
your CPU metrics,
your memory metrics,
your [INAUDIBLE] consumption.
Do not forget about that.
It's something that might be
important to do correlation
and to debugging your problems.
But essentially, use the
four pillars of observability
that we have described before.
They are like [INAUDIBLE],,
metrics, traces, exceptions,
core files.
Collect that information.
It will help you to
maintain that information
to do correlation and causation
and root cause analysis.
But move to the
system-based alert system.
By doing that, you
transition slowly.
Talk to the team that
is writing the software
and see if you are
collecting logs.
Talk to the people that are in
charge of the load balancers.
If you are using Google
Cloud, many of the load
balancers automatically
ingest that information
into Stackdriver.
So figure out what
is the information
that you want to
page on, what are
the metrics that are defining
how your service is operating.
Introduce a couple
of SLIs on them,
introduce a couple of SLOs
that define your objectives,
and then start measuring
the availability.
The transition assumes that your
teams are having all kinds of--
it works in a coherent manner.
Introducing SLOs and
targeting availability
requires the development
team in order
to do the thing that
we were talking about.
Once you burn your
error budget and you
don't have reliability
leeway left,
you have to get your teams,
your development teams,
to slow down in
putting new features,
slow down in pushing
for those releases that
may increase your risk.
At Google, we have identified
that introducing new changes--
even if it's
configuration changes,
releasing new binaries--
increase the error that
is being added to your system.
So add a system-based alert.
Lower this ability of
the system-based alert
in the beginning.
And then identify, if
you have an outage,
that it's been paging through
your cost-based alert.
If the system-based
alert is also paging,
identify the moments
that your alerts
are firing in the
cause-based alert
but are not firing in
your system-based alert
through your SLOs.
Maybe your users are
happy and you're just
paging your operators
without any reason.
And slowly transition
to increase
the severity of the
SLO-based alerting system
and decrease the severity
of the cause-based alert
once you feel more
comfortable with it.
The next thing
that you should do
is, those goals that we have
defined before, analyze them.
The analysis is done through
critical user journeys.
So get to your service,
talk to your developers,
identify the things
that are extremely
important to your service.
And based on those,
identify some of the SLIs
that increasingly will--
sorry-- that, over time,
will increase in complexity.
In the beginning, you
should aim for the basics,
like the simple things that
provide you the biggest
amount of information.
But later on, you will
introduce more complex SLIs,
like a system in which
you have to do a login.
It may have certain interactions
with taking authorization
tokens, bringing them back,
calling some other databases,
some external
service for payment.
So increase the
complexity of your service
once you get
comfortable with that.
The next thing that you do
is you rinse and repeat.
SLOs should never
be set in stone.
They change with your users.
They change with the
development of your features
and your service, with the
growth of your service,
with the importance of it.
You may be the leader in the
market and a lot of people
are relying on you.
So you need to move and create
that culture of revisiting
and reviewing what you
have defined so that you
can move as your service moves.
And on that, there's
much more information
about this topic in the two
books that we have published.
There is a URL over there
where you can actually get
the copies of the book in PDF.
And we have also
a Coursera course
that goes through the
entire workflow on how
to develop those SLIs, those
SLOs, in much more detail.
You have the URL so that you
can access it over there.
And with that, you
made it to the end.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]